here's a story from the Daily Mail
healing comes first fans send Justin
Bieber well wishes as he cancels the
remainder of his Justice World Tour amid
Health woes that's right did you guys
know that his face is paralyzed and uh
people are saying that they believe the
reason that he's canceling is because he
can't use his face anymore and uh
they're saying it's Ramsay Hunt syndrome
it's really sad and Phil's giving me
this look right now you you phrased it
you can't use your face anymore oh I
mean I don't know it's funny to me so uh
you know here's this 29 year old dude
suffering from something they that they
say that typically only affects people
over the age of 60.
he's still affected by this this was
like three months ago I think he he
first announced it this is I guess what
the it's being reported by a bunch of
celebrity gossip and Outlets that's the
reason the Ramsay Hunt Syndrome like
where we saw this a while ago he his
face was paralyzed but it causes it well
uh they're saying it's Ramsay Hunt a lot
of people thought it was uh what Bell's
Palsy okay caused by probably some kind
of medication perhaps some medication
perhaps that he was he was prescribed in
order to travel the world maybe about
adverse reaction or something maybe some
yeah to some kind of medication but we
don't know for sure recreational use of
medication I mean that that's possible
too to be honest all of the above but
they're saying it's chickenpox
they're saying that uh and you know I it
makes perfect sense yeah right because
we just heard that MSNBC host got
pericarditis and myocarditis from the
common cold so as we as we know that
these very common uh ailments can cause
things like
facial paralysis and swelling of the
lining around the heart
so it happens all the time I've learned
a lot since 2020. that's right oh and
heart attacks and strokes are way up
among young people and they're saying
that's caused by erythritol yeah yeah
that's what I've heard I've heard that's
right yeah all these keto diets so you
know
oh and chicken eggs they say we're
causing that too you know we we learned
a whole lot about the world and maybe if
we cut out erythritol chicken eggs avoid
chicken pox in the common cold these
heart attack strokes and pericarditis
and myocarditis will stop happening and
you know maybe Justin Bieber's cracking
raw eggs for breakfast and
he's doing keto diet so he's eating a
lot of egg and he's eating a lot of
erythritol he should have just stayed in
the pot he'd have been safe in the Pod
man well you know maybe did he ever say
why he thinks he got sick with this did
he ever say like I had uh adverse
reaction to something or any of that or
did he just say I think I think you said
Ramsay Hunt which they say it's like oh
he's got chickenpox and the virus hit
the nerve in his ear or something and
then it paralyzes your face and makes
you go deaf is it permanent uh I don't
know because like Bella I think you can
yeah it's temporary recover from right
yeah there's like a viral video of some
nurse or something that got Bell's Palsy
from I believe from some sort of
vaccination I'm not sure I'm not sure
which one I'm not sure which one no just
some sort of vaccination though but then
uh it goes away so it's like temporary
paralysis of the face or something like
that so you know I don't know I thought
it was kind of a big deal that one of
the biggest celebrities in the world
canceled a world tour this is one of the
most famous guys
and it's it's you know what's funny is
uh Eric Clapton's hands got paralyzed
you remember that you don't say yeah
early on in the pandemic I don't even
like call it a pandemic man that's so
gross it's just so weird all of these
things are happening around the same
time and uh
you know I gotta say talk to a doctor
about what's right for you and don't get
your medical advice from podcasters but
I honestly think there's a strong
possibility the next big Domino to fall
will be Mass vaccination
specific specific mass vaccination not
you know I think there's a lot of
vaccines that have been around for a
long time that have been tested over
several decades but I wouldn't be
surprised if come 2024 you're going to
see some news come out about
Adverse Events The increased risk we've
already started seeing reports that
young people are seeing an increase of
risk of myocarditis and pericarditis
despite the fact they're saying it's
caused by the common cold or whatever
they might say and then I wouldn't be
surprised if Donald Trump is running for
president and they say oh yeah you know
all these really bad things we're
showing you like Justin Bieber oh no oh
that's Trump's fault that was that was
Trump's fault is Donald Trump's uh
demonstration yeah his vaccine
yep blame his vaccine they'll blame him
and then they're not going to vote for
him it was because of warps and that's
how you convince convince conservatives
not to support Trump and then they'll
get behind it DeSantis what do you guys
think of Vivek Rama Swami as a political
candidate I don't think he's going to
win but he seems like an all right dude
yeah I don't know enough about him to
have a uh a formed opinion like a solid
opinion but uh the things that I have
heard are appealing the reason I bring
it up is because I'm I'm absolutely
disheartened by the way Donald Trump
handled the the uh covet stuff like he
he just handed it off to fauci in the
administrative State and then like was
like that's why I didn't even tell
people to go outside and get fresh air
or any of that that's why I think this
is the direction things will go that
they're gonna Something's Gonna Change
in the news we're already getting the
FBI and the doe saying Washington State
Department of energy saying that lab
leak is most likely the case which is in
a sense vindicating for Trump but then
they're going to come out and they're
going to be like yeah all these bad
things that was Trump's fault he doubled
down he wouldn't back off fauci who lied
lab leak Donald Trump that was under him
and so what's going to happen DeSantis
is going to win
we'll see well I mean I was very
critical of trump from the very start
even the 15 days to stop the spread or
whatever they called it flatten the
curve
um highly critical of him and handing
over basically the economy and the
entire government to fauci and Deborah
Burks and using highly flawed models
that were not tested as evidence to per
to continue the lockdowns then into
April of of 2020.
um and he really I mean I think he's
come out and said
he's expressed some regret but of course
he owns operation warp speed and you
have not seen him pull back on that at
all off of that at all
but DeSantis also did go along with the
lockdowns early on he went along with
some other mitigation factors including
the vaccine so his hands are not totally
clean I mean he has expressed more
regret I think and talked about the
lessons that he learned but look I was I
was in Florida the beginning of the
lockdown I mean it was it was locked out
yeah and gradually reopening and he was
signing executive emergency you know
declarations so
um if they're going to battle over that
I think ultimately DeSantis prevails
because he did come around and he did
open his State a little bit sooner than
others and that's the look The
Establishment we'll take it to Santa's
over a trump
really absolutely absolutely Democrats I
talked to they hate the sanctions sure
she watches Trump I mean they're gunning
for that guy already they want to win
right though they want to win but they
will take it to chance over Trump you
mean I'm not saying Ministry of State
yeah I'm not saying that they're going
to come out and be alike I'm voting for
DeSantis they're going to come out and
be like DeSantis is as bad as Trump then
when it comes to the election they will
put everything into helping DeSantis win
the primary to stop Trump because if it
came down to Democrats losing they would
prefer to sand us over Trump
easily do you think that do you think
santis or who do you think is more
beatable Trump or DeSantis from it from
a from a left-leaning perspective I
think I think well it's tough right now
right the Sanders has an advantage in a
lot of ways but he doesn't really have
that X Factor that Trump has that's
right and the the whole East Palestine
thing was very very good for Trump who's
Trump got as his advisors right now
because I think kushner's out and Ivanka
is not involved as far as I can tell so
who like advised Donald to go to
Palestine East Palestine or did he make
that decision my guess is he made it on
his own I mean I do think that that's
was part of his charm and success and
continues to be is that he would be the
one no one would really have to tell him
to do that you know he
he would do it on his own in terms of
his advisors I'm I'm not really sure
he's around him now I think Vivek Rama
Swami is a serious candidate in that
he's actually talking about how to solve
the situation which is to put our our
economy into uh uh what are they called
uh oh God oh God man uh basically to
invest our 401ks into non-woke
organizations oh anti-esg yes that is
his main thing it's not even he doesn't
even I mean he is anti-est but he's
actually talking about how to succeed
he's not talking about let's stop doing
ESG like that's part of it but he's
telling you what to do and he's done it
he's been doing it so it's like he is
doing it he'd be a fantastic maybe not a
military commander I don't know anything
about his foreign policy but I think if
if maybe a vice president because he's a
brilliant Economist the Pres the vice
president doesn't really have a whole
lot of a job to actually do and someone
like Vivek if he's got good ideas
someone like that might be better off in
a in a an Administration position where
they're writing policy where they're
actually crafting the policy Donald
Trump is good has good gut instincts but
the things that that had
tangible effect on the the
economy and and policy those were almost
all written by other people Donald
Trump's not a a policy guy he's a big
picture dude he's he's going to be like
go do this let's get this done the
anti-woke uh executive order that he
wrote that he signed that was written by
people like James Lindsay and and stuff
that that knew how to craft policy that
will achieve the ends that we want that
still is legal and is not straining the
law because we really do have a lot of
the tools at our disposal to to fix a
lot of the problems that we have so I
like Vivek but I don't think that he
would I don't know that he this alone is
enough for him for me to say that he
would make a good president it's not
exciting it's not nothing about going
anti-sja or fixing the economy is not
exciting it's yelling and calling people
names and making a big to do the ESG
stuff is the most important stuff going
right now it's not exciting you're right
but it is the most it will have the most
impact on this on society and it's the
most important thing to to it's it's the
economy if it goes bad violence will
increase if you want to stop violence
fix the economy if you want to make sure
people don't starve and Rob each other
fix the economy you know what Trump
needs to do I was thinking about that
whatever podcast that keeps getting
these viral Clips that's probably going
to become a massive show but you know
it's got its market cap and and that
joke where someone said get a bunch of
low-wit narcissistic women and you know
rag on them and you'll have a great show
that's a strategy right there for Trump
get Democrats who are of low wit and
sound really dumb and debate them it's
it's why why debate
smart people when you just make yourself
look dumb get in a debate stage with
stupid people and then it makes you look
really smart whether you're smart or not
you know what I mean like Trump needs to
put himself in positions where he's
debating really really dumb people so he
should offer up conversations with with
smaller channels and smaller podcasts
from the left that would kill for an
opportunity at the Limelight but there's
a reason why they don't have it and I'm
only half kidding think about this you
find a YouTube channel with 50 70 000
Subs leftist liberal kind of articulate
guy or lady not really that smart Trump
says I will do an interview with you
you then get Trump running circles
around a leftist liberal making them
look like a and those liberals
will do it in two seconds because
they're like I'm gonna get to interview
Trump this is going to be huge and then
Trump ends up boosting in the polls
because he looks smart yeah I think even
if he Donald Trump were to to come out
and look stupid about stuff it wouldn't
like stop people from voting for him
they I think people would more
appreciate his honesty and openness look
he does these interviews with the
corporate press all the time and they're
they're they're playing him every time
it's like he doesn't learn his lesson he
sits down he says here's what's going on
I'm going to do these things it'll be
tremendous and then they're like okay
let me write that down Trump is Hitler
and hates black people and uh we'll run
that and then Trump goes back again
three months later you wrote a really
nasty piece about me but I'll give you
another chance just Trump just just go
find the the up and comers who are
desperate for attention and then you
know do those interviews thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time